مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابع من
الرياض نبدا بالعناوين
تراكب لمحاكمه ترامب شرطه نيويورك تنشروا
30 الف شرطي استعدادا لاستجواب الرئيس
السابق
وبالتزامن مع محاكمه ترامب مخاوف لدى
الامريكيين من تكرار احداث الكابتن
نظام صحي جديد في السعوديه قيد الاستطلاع
تامين وطني وتوزيع عادل للخدمات على جميع
السكان
في الرابعه
وعملا بالماده 116 من الدستور ترفع الجلسه
لما بعد العيد
السياسيه مستمر في الكويت
الغانم يرفع جلسه البرلمان لعدم تشكيل
الحكم وعملا بالماده
ومعارضه ثقافيه توثق وتاريخ المسجد الحرام
لتجربه الزوار والمعتمرين في مكه المكرمه
يترقب ملايين الامريكيين والعالم محاكمه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في
نيويورك اليوم شرطه نيويورك قصتها اكثر من
30 الف شرطي بلباس رسمي وتسعه عشر الف
اخرين بلباس مدني لتامين هذه المحاكمه
التاريخيه
راسها القاضي اخوان مرشان الذي قرر عدم بث
المحاكمه على الهواء وسمح فقط باخذ باخذ
صور ثابته لترامب قبل بدء اجراءات
المحاكمه
واستعدادا لمحاكمته المقرره اليوم مصر
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
قادما من فلوريدا ووفقا للاعلام الامريكي
رحله ترامب بدات بمغادره منزله في بالام
بيتش وصولا الى برج ترامب في منهات في
نيويورك وبعدها سيصل الى محكمه منهات
وسيواجه الاستدعاء في اول لائحه اتهام
لرئيس الامريكي سابق عند الثانيه وخمسه
عشره دقيقه بتوقيت المحلي اي 18 والربع
بتوقيت جرينتش بعد الانتهاء سيغادر
الترامب نيويورك عائدا الى فلوريدا تحديدا
الى مقره
وسيعقد مؤتمرا صحفيا عند الثامنه وخمسه
عشره دقيقه عند منتصف الليل بتوقيت
[موسيقى]
من نيويورك من امام محكمه من هاتن تحديدا
تنضم الينا مديره مكتبه مكتب العربيه
البلبيسي مرحبا ناديه يوم تاريخي في
الولايات المتحده وفي نيويورك تحديدا هي
المدينه ربما التي جعلت التي قفزت بترامب
الى الساحه العالميه وظل العقود او ضلت
العقود جزءا لا يتجزا من تاريخ هذا الرجل
لكنها اليوم تقضيه وتحاكم في منظر مختلف
فالاجراءات كيف ستتم
اهلا بك يا خالد بالفعل هي محاكمه تاريخيه
لرئيس جدلي وبطاقيه اعلاميه غير مسبوقه
على الاطلاق طبعا الجميع هنا بعدسات
الكاميرات تنتظر دخول الرئيس ترامب للاسف
لن نراه لانه سيدخل من باب خلفي ولن يكون
هناك تغطيه مرئيه لهذه المحاكمه بطلب من
القاضي رغم ان محامي الشاهد الاكثر ربما
شهره وهو مايكل كوين الذي كان يعمل مع
ترامب ودخل السجن من اجل ترامب والبعض راب
انه كان كبش فداء له كان يامل ان يكون
بالفعل هناك تغطيه اعلاميه متلفزه حتى يرى
الامريكيين ماذا سيحدث لكن عن كل الاحوال
اريد ان اركز على ان هذه ليست بمحاكمه هذه
بدء اجراءات بمعنى بان الرئيس ترامب سيدخل
مع الشرطه السريه طبعا لانه رئيس سابق
يتمتع بهذه الخدمه حسب الدستور الامريكي
سيقول بانه غير عندما يتم فتح هذا الملف
ونستمع او سنعرف لاحقا لن نستمع لكن سنقرا
مع هذه الاتهامات التي نتوقع ان تكون اكثر
من 30 اتهاما لكن سنرى اذا كانت هناك
مفاجات يعني البعض يرى بانه المدعي العام
البراك يجب ان يكون لديه قضيه قويه جدا
حتى يستطيع القاضي بالفعل ان يقول يمكن ان
نستمر بالمحاكمه والا بامكان القاضي حتى
اليوم ان يقول بانه لا يوجد هناك ادله
قويه او ادله كافيه وبالتالي يغلق هذه
القضيه طبعا الرئيس ترامب سيستغل هذا طلب
طبعا من محاميه ان لا يكون هناك تقييد
لاداه وحتى الصوره التي تتخذ عاده للاشخاص
الذين يتهمون بجرائم قد لا ياخذها ويتسمى
لانه بتعرف هي حتى يعرف الناس من هو هذا
الشخص هو الرئيس ترامب معروف يعني لكنه
سيستغلها سياسيا وهو الذي يقول منذ اليوم
الاول بانه ضحيه لهذه المؤامرات من قبل
الديمقراطيين وخصوصا هذا المدعي العام
المعروف في نيويورك فقط في نيويورك قال
بانه يجب ان يقاد ترامب قبل ان يعرف ما هي
اكثر من 33 الف شرطي
موجودين الان ربما في ساحات نيويورك مشهد
غير مسبوق اغلقت فيه الشوارع كما يقال في
جميع انحاء المدينه ربما استعدادا لما هو
غير متوقع ناديه هل يمكن ان تكون الاجواء
صاخبه والى اي حد
لا اتوقع ذلك لانه اولا هذه اجراءات
احترازيه نيويورك لديها اكبر عدد ربما من
افراد الشرطه ولديهم خبره طويله منذ احداث
الحادي عشر من سبتمبر مرورا مره في
المدينه حتى الان وبالتالي نشر هذه القوات
واجراء احترازيل اكثر لتعلم الدرس مما حدث
في احداث الكابيتال في السادس من يناير
لماذا اعتقد انه لن يتكرر السيناريو ما
حدث في واشنطن اولا لانه لا يوجد عدد كبير
من مؤيدي ترامب يعني انا هنا منذ الامس لم
ارى حتى امام برج ترامب كان عشرات فقط من
مؤيدي الرئيس وليس مئات وليس الاف
النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه بانه الرئيس
ترامب نفسه لم يدعم مؤيدين يعني في احداث
الكابيتال كان يرى بان الانتخابات سرقت
منه بين قوسين وانها غير شرعيه وبالتالي
كان يطالب تقريبا بقلب نظام الحكم من خلال
وجودها هؤلاء المؤيدين الذين ذهبوا الى
مبنى الكونغرس ودخلوا الى مكتب نا
ونعرف باقي التاريخ يعني لكن هنا اعتقد
بانه الامر مضبوط امنيا لا نرى مظاهرات لا
مع ولا ضد حتى فقط هو الوجود الاعلامي
المكثف للصحفيين منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى
امام المحكمه وكما ذكرت بعد ان تقرا علي
هذه التهم لن يقضي وقتا طويلا هنا ربما
تستمر ما بين عشر دقائق الى نصف ساعه كما
عرفنا بعد ذلك سيتوجه الى مطار لاغواديا
في نيويورك وسيذهب الى مارا لارجو في
فلوريدا هذه الولايه التي اصبحت مكان
اقامته هاجر نيويورك طواعيه هذه المدينه
التي كانت يعني سجلت كل نجاحاته التجاريه
والماليه لكنه في النهايه بعد الانتخابات
قرر ان يتركها وان يعود
التهم ستعلن بعد هذه الجلسه اليوم
تعلم بشكل رسمي يعني عشان اعرف قدهم بشكل
رسمي نعم سنعرف سنعرف هذه التهم سيكون
هناك
كما نعرف 33 34 دهمه بعضها معظمها يعني
ليست خطيره لكن واحده منها حسب التسريبات
قد ترقى لجنايه وبالتالي قد يحاكم الرئيس
لاحقا لكن على كل الاحوال هو يوم تاريخي
لم يسبق ابدا للتاريخ الامريكي ان يرى
رئيس سابق يحاكم ياتي الى هنا في المحكمه
في منهج وتقدم لائحه اتهام ضده
ويعامل كمتهم طبعا هنا كل متهم هو بريء
حتى تثبت ادانته لكن فكره الاتهام نفسها
لرئيس سابق وادانه من قبل هيئه المحلفين
هي سجل يدخل التاريخ دون طويل لكم ايضا
ناديه في متابعتكم لهذه القضيه نيويورك
يعطيكم العافيه شكرا جزيلا لك بالتاكيد
سنتابع معك ومع الزملاء ايضا شبكه
المراسلين الموجودين الان في نيويورك وفي
غيرها من الولايات شكرا جزيلا لك ناديه
البلبيسي مديره مكتب العربيه في واشنطن
[تصفيق]
رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب قال
انه سيتم توجيه او سيتم توجيه اتهام اليه
في 33 تهمه في محكمه نيويورك اليوم
الثلاثاء
ترامبتهما المدعي العام في من هاته
بتسريب لا يحات الاتهام لوسائل الاعلام
واشار الرئيس الامريكي السابقي لانه لا
توجد تغييرات او مفاجات وانه غير مذنب
مؤكدا بانه يجب توجيه لائحه اتهام الى
المدعي العام نفسه حيث تسربت محتوياته
لوائح الاتهام المعلق الى الصحافه
وردا على مطالب وسائل اعلام بالسماح لها
ببث المحاكمه على الهواء او التقاط
فيديوهات اكد القائد اخوان مرشان الذي
يتراس الجلسه اليوم ان محاكمه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب لن تداعى على الهواء
مباشره القادمه شدد على اهميه هذه
المحاكمه التاريخيه مؤكدا بانه سيتم
السماح فقط لبعض المصورين بالتقاط صور في
قاعه المحكمه قبل بدء الاجراءات رسميه
معنويات ترامب قبل المحاكمه كشفت المحامي
الينها بلتي مثلت الرئيس الامريكيه السابق
في قضايا مدنيه لشبكه سي ان ان معنويات
ترامب جيده وانه مستعد للمحاكمه ويعرف
جيدا ماذا عليه ان يفعل على حد وصفها اما
فيما يخص الخطه الخاصه بفريق الدفاع قالت
هذا في مقابله على قناه
انه تم التخطيط ولكل شيء بالكامل مشيره
الى ان فريق الدفاع يعمل على التنسيق
والتعاون مع الجميع للتاكد من وجود او من
عدم وجود مشاكل
ينضم الينا الدكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في
السيئون السياسيه الامريكيه ومن نيويورك
ينضم الينا هناك اكرما المدعي العام
الامريكي السابق مرحبا بكم ابدا بضيفي من
نيويورك سيد نايكا كرمان الان هذه
المحاكمه التي ستبدا اجراءاتها هذا اليوم
بالنسبه
كل ما يحدث الان ما يحيط بها من ناحيه
التحرك في نيويورك وصوله الى المحاكمه شكل
العام الذي سيجري هل هو ياتي في اطار
قانوني بحث لا توجد فيه اي تدخلات
العمليه
القضائيه لن يكون هناك محاكمه حتى سنه
كامله
وجهت له تهم بعده جرائم لا نعرف تفاصيلها
حتى الان فلم يتم الافصاح عنها ولن يتم
ذلك حتى يقف امام القاضي هذا المساء وبعد
ذلك سيكون هو من يقرر ومحاميه
ان كان يقول انه مطلب ام غير متذنب ومن تم
الوثائق التي ستقدم هذه ستحدد وسيكون هناك
بعض الاجراءات
وفقا
للاتهام والادانه والادله
وبالتاكيد هذه عمليه طويله
لن يطر للعوده الى المحكمه حتى تصبح
القضيه جاهزه لمحاكمه امام هيئه محلفين هل
سيحتجزم ام انه سيبقى حرا اثناء مداوله
هذه القضيه على مدى شهور القادمه
ما يحدث عاده
يتم بضع
مخصصات ماليه لضمان
انهم سيعودون للمحكمه وان لم يتم فان
المحكمه تحتفظ بالمال
وبالتالي في هذه الحاله في هذه القضيه
افترض انه
سيتم اطلاق صراحه ولن يكون هناك
كفاله ولكن ستكون عمليه سريعه اليوم
كم من الوقت ستستغرق هذه المحاكمه خاصه
نعرف بان ترامب مثلا في قضايا عده كان
يعني
يطيل اجراءاتها فهل يمكن ان يتعرض او
تتعرض هذه القضيه لنفس هذا النهجه ونفس
هذا الامر
ان هذا لن ياخذ وقت طويل هذا الصباح الا
ان العمليه منذ بدايتها حتى نهايتها
ستستغرق عاما
طيب واضح سيد عقيل الخبير في الشؤون
السياسيه الامريكيه هذه الحادثه احدثت
يعني انقساما في شارع الامريكي ينظر اليها
الان من كل انحاء العالم على انها
يوم مختلف تماما في تاريخ السياسه
الامريكيه بشكل عام عندما يحاسب رئيس وهنا
يطرح السؤال ربما هل كانت القرار قرار
محاكمه ترامب قرارا حكيما
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه طبعا لا نستطيع ان
نقرر حكمه القرار من عدمه علينا يعني نرى
التهم
تعلن ثم اجراءات المحاكمه
يمكن التاكد من جديتها ومن جديه الادله
انا بتصوري يعني انه الادله قويه راسخه
لانها تقوم اساسا على اعتراف محامي ترامب
مايكل
للقضاء وتقديمه تسجيلا صوتيا حديث بينه
وبين ترامب بخصوص اعطاء مع
الممثله الاباحيه اعطائها المال بالكاش ثم
يظهر هذا المال في السجلات
المدعي العام في نيويورك السابقا
لم يتولى او لم يدفع لم يرفع قضايا رفعت
ضد الرئيس ترامب لكن لم يتصور انها كافيه
لمحاكمته فحذر يعني هذا المدعي العام حذر
واعتقد انه ما كان سيذهب في هذا الدرب على
هذه الماره لولا تاكده من رصانه الادله
يعني الاهم ان هناك فاعل شارك في هذه
القضيه هو الان يقف معهم مقابل تخفيف
الحكم عليه ما يسمى صفقه قانونيه خارج
اطار المحاكم تسمح بالتخفيف الحكم عنه او
حتى اعطاه من الحكم مقابل تقديم ادله ضد
المتهم الرئيسي ترامب في العاده هذه قضايا
صناعه قويه ابقى معي ضيفاي اريد فقط ان
اشير الى ان هذه المحاكمه سببت الكثير من
التوترات على الساحه السياسيه الامريكيه
وسط مخاوف ايضا من تصيد امني في مناعه
شبيه بحادثه الكابتن في واشنطن
مع اختلاف طبيعه مثول الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه بتهم
جنائيه واحداث الكابيتول الا ان هناك
مخاوف من تكرار ذات السيناريو فوضى وعنف
وتخريب رغم ان مؤشرات ذلك قليله وفقا
للسلطات الامنيه الامريكيه لكن لمعرفه
الاختلافات بين المناسبتين يجب اولا
التذكير باحداث الكابيتول
شغب الكابيتول حدث عام 2021 حين اقدم حشد
عنيف من انصار الرئيس دونالد ترامب على
مهاجمه مبنى الكابيتول في العاصمه واشنطن
احداث فتحت معها اكبر تحقيق في تاريخ
وزاره العدل الامريكيه ويواجه اكثر من 930
شخصا اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم فيدراليه
الامر المشترك ما بين احداث الكابيتول
وبين مثول ترامب امام المحكمه بقضايا
جنائيه هو خطاب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
لمناصريه لكن المختلفه هو توقيت الخطابين
في احداث الكابيتول كان خطابه ناريا
ظهر فيه قبل ساعات من الواقعه واثار
المئات من انصاره اما فيما يتعلق بمحاكمته
في من هات فاعلن الرئيس الامريكي انه
سيظهر علنا بخطاب لكن هذه المره بعد ساعات
من سماعه لائحه الاتهام الموجهه له فحوى
الخطاب غير معروفه حتى الان لكن المعروف
هو تاثير ترامب على انصاره وفي المقابل
ردات الفعل غير المتوقعه للمناهضين له
احداث الكابيتول مثلت درسا للسلطات
الامنيه بدات بعدها بمسح امني واسع
للمشاركين وتبادل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
بشكل اسرع وعلى الارض تجهيز مواقع الحدث
بحواجز معدنيه واغلاق الطرق وحتى قوى
بشريه ضخمه تغطي مساحه واسعه استعدادا لاي
طارئ
دكتور عقيل ما هي احتمالات بالفعل ان يعاد
نفس المشهد الذي حدث في الكابتول في
نيويورك او في غيرها من المناطق يعني
خلال فتره المحاكمه التي قد تستغرق شهور
العده
يعني لا اتصور على الاقل في هذه المرحله
المبكره انه الرئيس الاسبق
لهذا وتعلم من درس
الكافيتو لانه يعني اقترب الامر حقيقه
لتوجيه اتهام له يعني شتى الاشياء ايضا
ليس من الحكمه بالنسبه له الان هذه على
الاقل نصائح محاميه يستخدم نيويورك
المدينه التي سيحاكم فيها ان يستخدمها
لتحشيد لمظاهرات ضد المحكمه يعني وضد
السلطه القضائيه اعتقد يعني انه هذا الان
هو امره
بيد قاضي فمن المهم ان لا يستفز القاضي
باي اي اي تكن الاشياء التي بيد الرئيس
ولا يستطيع ان يهز سلطه هذا القاضي
بالامكان الطلب تغيير القاضي نقل المحاكمه
الى مكان اخر فمن وجهه نظر استراتيجيه من
الافضل الان
يستفز السلطات القضائيه في نيويورك خارج
نيويورك يمكن يعني يحشد الناس فلوريدا في
اماكن اخرى تبدو انه هذه هي استراتيجيه
التاكيد على تجاوز الجوانب القانونيه
والقضائيه في الموضوع والتاكيد على
الجوانب السياسيه
وبتصوري هو يريد هذا المشهد ان يطول اقصى
ما يمكن في اثناء خوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
لانه يريد ان يستخدمها نقطه تحشيد ضد
خصومه اذا انتهت الانتخابات الرئاسيه
اعتقد هو سيذهب الى حسم هذا الملف سريعا
يعني صفقه خارج المحاكم مصففه قانونيه في
هذا القليل
اسمح لي فقط نشير الى هذا الاخبار العاجله
التي ياتينا الان نشاهد هذه الصور من مقر
حلف النيتو في بروكسل حيث يرفع الان علم
فنلندا اعلان بانضمام هذه الدوله الى حلف
الناتو بعد مداولات استغرقت وقتا طويلا
وبعد ربما تحركات سريعه بدات انتهت هذا
اليوم وبدات بعد احداث الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه اليوم يعلن عن انضمام فنلندا
رسميا الى حلف النيتو وكان
قد اعلن بان
سيطبق على كافه الحقوق والالتزامات
وستصبح دوله كامله العضويه في حلف الاطلس
[موسيقى]
تعود الى الحدث الابرز هذا اليوم محاكمه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب التي تبدا
اجراءاتها هذا اليوم من نيويورك ونذهب مره
اخرى الى نيويورك الى نيكا كرمال المدعي
العام الامريكي السابق سيد
الاجراءات كيف ستتم هل من ثغرات يمكن
لترامب ان يستفيد منها في هذه المحاكمه
متى يمكن له بالفعل ان يطالب بتغيير هذه
المحكمه او مكانها الى محكمه اخرى هذه
الالتزامات او الالتماسات هل ستاخذ وقتا
طويلا هل ستؤثر على وقت مداولاتها هذه
القضيه هل هناك احتمالات بان ينتهي الامر
بالترام فعليا في السجن ام لا
بدايه نعم يمكن ان يطالب بتغيير مكان
المحكمه
لكن مره ثانيه لابد ان يبقى المكان في
ولايه نيويورك
والنجاح هوائيل فمن سبب يدعو للقيام بذلك
هو النشاطات التي يتهم عليها حدثت في
منهات
وفي سجل اعمال كلها حدثت في
قد ياخذ حجه ان بعض الدفعات الماليه على
الاقل التي دفعت لمايكل كوهن حدثت عندما
كانت ترامب رئيسا وبالتالي هنا لا ينبغي
ان يكون لمحكمه الولايه سلطه للفصل في
قانونيه هذه الممارسات
الدفعات ما زالت فيها انتهاك لقانون
نيويورك وتزوير سجلات
شركه ترامب هي انتهاك القانون نيويورك
وبالتالي
المساله ستمضي قدما ولا اعتقد ان هذه
الحجه يكون لها اي وزن في المحاكمه او
تغير رايي الادعاء اما التهم
الاخرى
والادانه لا اعتقد انها ستكون ناجحه في
نيويورك
فكان هناك
مساله
الجائحه ومساله
ان يكون شخص خارج ولايه نيويورك وهو
الرئيس مثلا سيكون هناك الكثير من المسائل
التي ستوجه على الادانه وتتخذ بعض الوقت
والدفاع سيكون عليه
وقته لاحسن هذه
المسائل وستستغرق المحكمه وقتا
لتقلل هذه الاجراءات هذا هو الجزء الذي
نراه خلال الاشهر القادمه مع تقدم هذه
المحاكمات دكتور عقيل ربما الان عن مدى
تاثير هذه المحاكمه على حظوظ ترامب وعلى
شعبيتها هل بالفعل يمكن ان تصب هذه
المحاكمه في صالحه ان تعيده
منتصرا او فائزا ربما الى واشنطن للبيت
الابيض مجددا كما يسال البعض
يعني انه لن يكسب جمهورا جديدا وان
ما
بمعنى عدديا لن يصنع هذا الامر فارقا لكنه
في اوساط الحزب الجمهوري الانتخابات
البدائيه الابتدائيه التي يقوم بها الحزب
الجمهوري برايمري اعتقد هذه ستساعده كثيرا
في ان يفوز في هذه الانتخابات ولحد الان
هو المرشح رقم واحد اما على النطاق الوطني
الامريكي لا اعتقد وضعه صعب علينا ان
نتذكر في انتخابات 2016 والتي فاز فيها
بالرئاسه خسرت تصويت الشعبي بمليونين
وتسعمائه الف صوت فارق هي هي حصلت اكثر من
في انتخابات 2020 ضد الرئيس بايدن خسر
بحدود
7,7 ملايين طبعا هذه قبل ان تظهر مشكله
الكافيتو ومحاوله اقتحامها وهذه المشاكل
القانونيه الذي حسم الانتخابات في 2020
واعتقد هذا ربما سالت منتخبات المقبله هو
جمهور الذي لا ينتمي لحزب الجمهوري من
يسمون بالمستقلين الذين ليس لديهم قرار
هؤلاء
يخسرهم ترامب اكثر فاكثر من يسمون
بالحائرين لا يعرفون لمن سيصوتون في ظل
هذه الاجراءات والتواصل يعني الخطاب الذي
يستخدمه
اعتقد سيخسر المزيد منهم فعلى نطاق وطني
اعتقد حظوظه قليله جدا سيتذكر من سريعا
جدا لم يعد لديه المزيد هذه المحاكمه هل
يمكن ان تقود الى محاكمات اخرى في ملفات
متهم فيها او قد يتهم بها ترامب ولكن
الكثير من القضايا التي قد ترفع عليه مثل
ما حدث بالكاتب الكابت على سبيل المثال
سريع
جورج هناك في جورجيا مرتبطه
بتدخله في انتخابات
تلك الولايه هذه القضيه قويه لان هناك
مسؤولين اخرين وسيكون هناك اخرين الى جانب
ترامب واتوقع ان هذه التهمه تقدم
ويكون فيها ادانا قبل نهايه هذا الشهر اما
بالنسبه لتحقيق وزاره
الدفاع حول اعاقه ترامب لعمل الحكومه في
مذكره الجلب
يبدو ان الدليل قوي جدا وهذا سيؤدي الى
ادانه وهناك التحقيق في مساله تورط ترامب
ما حدث في الكابتل في السادس من يناير ليس
لدينا معلومات عن ذلك الان الا ان من
الصعب ان نحدد ذلك الموقف
وهذه كلها قضايا
على ترامب ان يتعامل معها خلال الساده
القادمه
دكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في الشؤون
السياسيه الامريكيه شكر جزيلا لكم
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل مجلس التعاون
الخليجي يؤكد ان الظروف مواتيه لبدء
محادثات لحل سياسي في اليمن
ترقبه لمحاكمه دونالد ترامب شرطه نيويورك
تنشر 30 الف شرطي استعدادا استجواب الرئيس
السابق
بالتزامن مع محاكمه ترامب مخاوف ولد
الامريكيين من تكرار احداث الكابتن
نظام صحي جديد في السعوديه قيد الاستطلاع
تميل وطني وتوزيع عادل للخدمات على جميع
السكان
وعملا بالماده 116 من الدستور ترفع الجلسه
لما بعد العيد
جمود السياسيه مستمر في الكويت الغانم
يرفع جلسه البرلمان لعدم تشكيل الحكومه
ومعارضه ثقافيه توثق وتاريخ المسجد الحرام
اثراء لتجربه الزوار والمعتمرين في مكه
المكرم
اهلا بكم من جديد قال امين مجلس التعاون
الخليجي جاسم البديوي ان الظروف مواتيه
لبدء محادثات سلام والتوصل لحل سياسي في
اليمن
البداوي في بيان اليوم الثلاثاء الى وحده
الصف واعلاء مصلحه اليمن العليا لانعما
بالسلام والامن والاستقرار
2022 وافق مجلس الوزراء السعودي برئاسه
الملك سلمان على تاسيس شركه الصحه القابضه
والموافقه على تنظيم مركز التامين الصحي
الوطني وقبل ايام ما طرح مشروع النظام
الصحيه الجديد لاستطلاع زميلنا شهد
المتروك تعرفنا اكثر على هذا المشروع
اذا التحول الصحي في السعوديه يسير بخطن
ثابته حيث طرح مؤخرا مشروع نظام الصحي
لاخذ الاراء حياله عبر منصه استطلاع
التابعه للمركز السعودي للتنافسيه ويستمر
استقبال المشاركات حول المشروع حتى السابع
والعشرين من ابريل الجاري ما الذي يهدف
اليه مشروع نظام الصحي الجديد في السعوديه
ابرز المستهدفات تتمثل في تسهيل الوصول
الى الخدمات الصحيه وتعزيز الوقايه ضد
الامراض والاوبئه اضافه الى خفض معدلات
الوفاه المبكره من الامراض غير المعديه
التامين الصحي الوطني اهم تحول ستشهده
السعوديه في القطاع الصحي مستقبلا وذلك
وفقا لمشروع النظام الجديد الذي اوضح من
المستفيدين من التامين وقسمهم على عده
فئات اولا جميع المواطنين غير المشمولين
بتامين صحي توفره لهم الجهات التي يعملون
فيها
ثانيا المواطنون السعوديون العاملون في
القطاعين العام والخاص وافراد اسرهم وفق
اليه معينه تمنع تعارض خدمات التامين
الوطني والتامين الخاص ابناء السعوديات
وازواجهن وزوجات المواطنين السعوديين
الاجنبيات اضافه الى غير السعوديين
العاملين في قطاعات حكوميه سيشمل هم
التامين الصحي الوطني وفيما يتعلق
بالمنشاءات الصحيه فقد نص مشروع النظام
الجديد على ضروره التوزيع العادل والمناسب
لاحتياجات السكان في كل المناطق وفق جوده
عاليه ومستدامه
الى الكويت حيث رفع رئيس مجلس الامه مرزوق
الغانم الجلسه العاديه الى ما بعد عيد
الفطر وذلك لعدم حضور الحكومه وعدم صدور
مرسوم تشكيل الحكومه الجديده وعدم اكتمال
النسب
نظرا الى عدم حضور الحكومه وعدم صدور
المرسوم بتشكيل الحكومه الجديده حتى الان
ولعدم اكتمال النصاب وعملا بالماده 116 من
الدستور ترفع الجلسه لما بعد العيد وذلك
نظرا لتزامن موعد الجلسه القادمه مع العشر
الاواخر من رمضان ومع عطله عيد الفطر وذلك
حسب ما جرى عليه في الاعوام السابقه
بدات رئاسه شؤون الحرمين في الحرم المكي
تنفيذ المرحله الثانيه من خطتها التشغيليه
من خلال تحديد مسارات اضافيه للمعتمرين
واخرى للزوار اضافه الى العمل على زياده
الخدمات التي يحتاجها المعتمر والزائر
داخل المسجد وفي ساحاته وانتشار المراقب
المدني الذي يساعد المعتمرين على الاجابه
على متطلباتهم وكان الرئيس العام لشؤون
الحرمين اعلنا نجاح خطه الرئاسه العشر
الاوائل من شهر رمضان المبارك
الحرم المكي الشريف ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه نصفيا اهلا هاني هاني ماذا لديك
اليوم
نعم اذا كاميرات العربيه ترصد وتواكب ايضا
المعتبرين والزوار ودخولهم وايضا حركه
خروجهم من المسجد الحرام الى مقر اقامتهم
والعكس كذلك طبعا كما نشاهد من خلال
الكاميرا التي نرصدها الان
ويتبين لنا ايضا اعداد المعتمرين الذين
يطوفون في صحن المطاف وايضا الموقع الذي
اتواجد فيه وهو في الطابق الثالث وهو احد
الطوابق التي خصصتها السعوديه بان تكون
مهيا ومجهزه للمعتبرين وبما اننا نتحدث
تحديدا في هذا الوقت وهو وقت الذروه نشاهد
اعداد المعتبرين الذين يقومون
بالطواف في الطابق الثالث وايضا رغم اننا
نتواجد في الطابق الثالث ولكن نشاهد في
هذا الطابق ايضا دورين او طابقين ايضا
العلوي هو خصص للعربات المتحركه والك
وكذلك الطابق الثالث وهو السفلي يعتبر الى
قسمين قسم للمشاه وقسم ايضا خصص للعربات
المتحركه
والكهربائيه ويتبين لنا كيف هي الحركه
السلسه وفق خطه تنظيميه يشرف عليها قوات
ورجال امن من قوات امن الحج والعمره هذه
بعض الخدمات التي او الخدمات التي تقدمها
السعوديه اليوم وهي تعتبر من ضمن الخطه
التشغيليه الثانيه والتي بدات فيها
السعوديه بعد ان اعلن الرئيس العام لرئاسه
شؤون الحرمين عن نجاح الخطه الاولى في
العشره الاوائل طيب ماذا لدينا في الجهه
اليسرى هنا في ايضا نواكب ايضا في الصوره
الاخرى صحن المطاف وكذلك ايضا نرصد
الطوابق الاخرى التي خصصتها رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين في ايضا منح المعتمرين كذلك دخول
الزوار وايضا تحت لهم امكانيه فرصه
الاستفاده من الطوابق الاخرى كي يقومون
باداء اركانهم طبعا عندما نتحدث ما هو
الفرق بين الخطه الاولى التشغيليه وكذلك
الخطه التشغيليه الثانيه فاننا نتحدث
اليوم ان الخطه التشغيليه الاولى كان هناك
عدد الابواب المتاحه للدخول المعتمرين
والزوار اكثر من 166 بابا سوف يضاعف العدد
الابواب في الخطه التشغيليه الثالثه او
عفوا الثانيه بحيث يصل الى اكثر من 200
باب وايضا المياه زمزم التي يستفيد منها
المعتمر والزائر ايضا سوف تكون هناك بدلا
من استهلاكهم في المرحله الاولى اكثر من
15 مليون لتر سوف يضاعف هذا الرقم قد يصل
الى 25 مليون لتر قد يزيد عن هذا الرقم
وايضا
زياده عدد عدد العربات المتحركه وكذلك
الكهربائيه سوف يضاعف الى عدد من المسارات
في حاله احتاجت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين الى ان
تكون هناك زياده في عددها متى ما كان
اعداد المعتمرين وكذلك الزوار في ازدياد
هذه هي الحركه الطبيعيه وهذا هو الوضع
الحالي الذي تواكبه كاميرا العربيه هنا في
الطابق الثالث وكذلك من الكاميرا الاخرى
وايضا الكاميراتها المنتشره على المسجد
الحرام من خلال حركه المعتقلين والزوار
شكرا جزيلا لك من الحرم المكي الشريف اذا
المراسل العربيه نسبيا
معرضه ثقافيه بجوار المسجد الحرام تروي
بعضا من حكايه وقصص الحرم المكي عبر
التاريخ سلسله من الحرمين مع سلطان السلوى
[موسيقى]
لم تعد زياره المسجد الحرام تقتصر على
اداء العمره او الصلاه بل توسعت لتكون
تجربه اكثر ثراء للمعتمرين والزوار هذه
ثلاثه معارض تقافيه تستقبلهم بتقنيه
الواقع الافتراضي والذكاء الاصطناعي طوال
ايام شهر رمضان
المعرض ولله الحمد يشهد اقبالا كبيرا ويضم
مجموعه من المقتنيات التاريخيه والتراثيه
مثل الحوامل التي كانت تحمل كسوه الكعبه
المشرفه
والاواني التي كانت تستخدم في سقايه ما
زمزم في المسجد الحرام ويشهد المعرض في
المتوسط 500 زائر في الساعه ولله الحمد
تروي المعارض المقامه في التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه حكايه وتاريخها بئر زمزم وكسوه
الكعبه فضلا عن المراحل التاريخيه التي مر
بها الحرم المكي من خلال المقتنيات
المعروضه التي يعود تاريخها الى اكثر من
مئه عامه جدا ممتازه جدا استفدت فيه كتير
جدا ما كنتش اعرف بعمق البركه كان كام
والمياه بتتدفق ازاي وهي موجوده فين وانت
عارفتها من هنا من المعرض عن طريق المكتبه
الرقميه ما شاء الله
انه كيف ما شاء الله
حضراتكم وتقنياتكم الجيده
من ناحيه كسره الكعبه واتقانها ويظهرها
بالمظهر اللاقمي دينيا
على العموم معرض ما شاء الله اكثر من
اربعين الف معتمر ومصلل قاموا بزياره
المعارض الثلاثه حتى اليوم حاملين معهم
قصصا وذكريات ومعرفه عن تفاصيل وتاريخ
المسجد الحرام من الحرم المكي سلطان
السلمي العربيه
اذا نعود مره اخرى لمتابعه ربما احد اهم
الاحداث كذلك التي تجري هذا اليوم وهو حدث
تاريخي بانضمام فنلندا لحلف شمال الاطلسي
نتابع من بروكسل الان
كلمه
[موسيقى]
تجمع توحده قيمنا وحريتنا
وديمقراطيتنا كلنا نقف سويا للحمايه
وللدفاع عن بعضنا بعضا كلنا للجميع
والجميع للكل
رئيس
يسرني ان اكون معك اليوم في هذا اليوم
العظيم شكرا على قيادتكم الرائعه وعملكم
الدؤوب
لتحقيق هذا اليوم
انا فخور بان اكون
امين العام للامم المتحده الذي يرحب بنيتو
للتحالف نرحب بكم
اذا كانت هذه كلمتنا من العام لخلف شمال
الاطلسيه
والتي تاتي ضمن المراسيم والبروتوكوليه
لانضمام فنلندا الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
هذه الاجراءات التي ستنتهي بعد قليل ربما
برفع علم فنلندا بين اعلام دول حلف شمال
الاطلسيدا تصبح بذلك او بهذا القرار دوله
فنلندا العضو
الحادي والثلاثين في حلف شمال الاطلسي
ونتابع معكم الان كذلك كلمه رئيس فنلندا
في
بعد قرار انضمام
تايلندا الى حلف الناتج
القرار بالتاكيد سيعتبر قرار تاريخي وتحول
استراتيجي ايضا مهم
اثارته ربما حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وبذلك
يزداد عدد الدول المتحالفه مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تمنح
دوله واحده على الحدود مع روسيا
تاريخيا فنلندا هي الدوله التي تعرضت
للغزو من الاتحاد السوفيتي في عام 1939 مع
ذلك وطوال فتره الحرب البارده بقيت خارج
النيتو
وربما هذا القرار او هذه العضويه هي اسرع
عمليه عضويه في تاريخ التحالف الحديث
استقر ربما استكمال عمليات المصادقه على
عضويه فنلندا اقل من عام ربما هذا الامر
يجعلها كما قلنا اسرع عمليه عضويه في
تاريخ الحلف كانت فنلندا وكذلك
السويد تقدمت بطلب الانضمام الى خلف
النيتو بعد الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وكان
في المقابل
لبعض الدول تحديدا لتركيا وهنغاريا
والاسباب مختلفه خاصه بكل منهما ربما كان
لها دور كبير في تاخير
الموافقه على الانضمام انضمام فنلندا
وكذلك السويدي
اليوم
وبعد ربما اكثر من اسبوع او اكثر من ذلك
قليلا وبعد ان تصوت البرلمان التركي
لازاله العقبه الاخيره امام فنلندا تصبح
كما نشاهد هذه الدوله فنلندا
عضوا رسميا في حلف الناتو نشاهد الان
مراسم الاحتفال والتي ستختم برفع علم
فنلندا كدوله ضمن
دول حلف الناتو
الختام بالعنوي
ترقبون لمحاكمه ترامب شرطه نيويورك تنشر
30 الف شرطي استعدادا لاستجاب الرئيس
الامريكيين من تكرار احداث الكابت
نظام صحي جديد في السعوديه قيد الاستطلاع
تامين وطني وتوزيع عادل للخدمات على جميع
السكن
وعملا بالماده 116 من الدستور ترفع الجلسه
لما بعد العيد والجمود السياسيه في الكويت
مستمر الغانم يرفع جلسه البرلمان لعدم
تشكيل الحكومه
ثقافيه توثق تاريخ المسجد الحرام متران
لتجربه الزوار والمعتمرين في مكه المكرمه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]